[Música]
yo soy gracia de las rocas y mi nación
méxico es el país de américa latina con
mayor brecha salarial y desgraciadamente
está de moda
por ejemplo tres cuartas partes de las
interacciones que suceden en redes
sociales que critican o rechazan las
matemáticas son hechas por mujeres
cuántas veces no vivimos este tema de
uso la calculadora está para sumar dos
más dos soy no soy perfecta soy guapa
pues se cree que las tareas de ciencias
tecnología ingeniería y matemáticas
también conocidas como las tareas estén
son exclusivas para hombres
esto será cierto habrá diferencias
biológicas o será un tema sociocultural
en mi caso estaba claro que me era
permitido no sobresalir en el campo que
dije es más no era importante y papá me
convenció de estudiar administración de
empresas para asegurar un futuro y no
complicarnos la vida vengo de familia de
ingenieros y desde muy pequeña entendido
que estos campos de estudio eran más
bien para hombres no aunque yo era una
alumna muy muy buena en matemáticas y
ciencias
yo tenía claridad que mis tres hermanos
y yo éramos diferentes
ellos eran los campeones y yo la
princesa yo necesitaba una carrera que
se adaptaba a cualquier circunstancia
por si me casaba pronto como decía mi
mamá
y las princesas somos frágiles necesitan
que alguien la rescate no puedes
solucionar problemas por ellas mismas
son delicadas y perfectas y si te sales
de ese estereotipo como mujer no vales
tan fácilmente acepta
este mensaje como al mujer lo recibes en
todos lados en las películas en redes
sociales en la televisión en la escuela
hasta en los regalos de cumpleaños
cuántas veces no decidimos por ejemplo a
un niño regalarle un lego y a la niña
siempre es un mejor regalo una muñeca o
un estuche de manicura
y como no va a estar de moda ser tonta
si a los tres años de interior estamos
que los hombres son superiores a los
seis años las mujeres empezamos a
alejarnos de las actividades que son
para gente muy muy inteligente y nos
alejamos de estas actividades a los diez
años ya nos cuesta trabajo dar nuestra
opinión según datos de grasa libre
aunque las pruebas de teams y de pizza
indiquen que somos iguales o hasta
mejores que tenemos hasta mayor
capacidad en las tareas éstas de estén
de ciencias tecnología ingeniería y
matemáticas nuestra auto-confianza dice
lo contrario todavía hace muy poco
tiempo buscando y llevar a fiestas de
experimentos a las niñas y los niños las
mamás me vestían es el concepto estaba
increíble para su hijo pero que podían
darles para mí para su hija la princesa
una fiesta de spa o qué concepto pudiera
ser interesante para ellas y saben mamá
el resultado de esto es que el 64 por
ciento de las ocupaciones peor peor
paradas las ocupamos las mujeres pues
sólo el 8 por ciento de las niñas
estamos interesadas en estudiar estas
áreas en estas carreras de stem ciencias
tecnología ingeniería
les cuento un poco mi historia tras una
crisis económica familiar en la que mi
papá no podía pagar mi carrera
universitaria y mamá se quedó
simplemente paralizada creo que era
finalmente el rol que le tocaba de
acuerdo a su época pero ellos de alguna
manera vienen sembrando algo distinto en
esta crisis descubrí que las princesas
en realidad somos apasionadas
resilientes y con una espíritu
emprendedor de veras sin credo ni
quebrantable
como una beca del deportivo deportiva la
logré pagar mis estudios universitarios
y desarrollarme de una manera no exitosa
en el campo de mercadotecnia y
comunicación y logré ser directora a los
27 años de una formación al tiempo
después le comenté con mi verdadera
vocación que es la educación en este
reconectarme conmigo misma conozco a
mariah con tensor y su método de
enseñanza el cual lo desarrolló a partir
del pensamiento científico la historia
de maria montessori y su movimiento
global sin duda fue un parteaguas en mi
vida fue la primera médico de italia y
todos sus estudios basados justamente en
el método científico hace que la
educación y si no que la educación del
mundo se transformará radicalmente
gracias a ella por primera vez las niñas
y los niños fueron el centro del salón
de clases descubren con evidencia
científica la importancia de aprender
con las manos y experimentar de crear de
asumir los errores como base del
aprendizaje como lo propone justamente
la educación de estilo
con esto en mente con mi inspiración
todos los días me pongo mi capa de login
step para cambiar alguno así e impulsado
por más de 20 años
justamente el pensamiento científico
como el camino hacia el desarrollo
sostenible en el bienestar social hoy la
iniciativa que encabezó que se llama
movimiento skip se ha convertido en un
movimiento regional que impulse la
educación el talento estima los empleos
del futuro de innovación con un toque
muy especial es esta visión social e
incluyente en 2014 fue premiada con el
premio nacional al emprendedor en mi
país y al siguiente año con el premio
nacional de calidad recientemente fue
reconocida como una de las 100 mujeres
líderes entre externa a nivel global y
premiada como game changer para los
global awards lo cual me da muchísima
esperanza
de que vamos por el camino correcto
porque cada vez estoy de alguna manera
más convencida de que estos esfuerzos
ayudarán a que américa latina' cuente
con tal es invencible para enfrentar el
siglo 21 hoy me doy cuenta que
necesitaba conocer la historia de maría
montessori para visualizar me a mí misma
en este camino de éxito creo que como yo
hay muchas niñas y adolescentes que
necesitan de estas historias exitosas de
mujeres exitosas para inspirarse muchas
veces me han preguntado que por qué me
dedico a impulsar esta educación hoy
estoy clara impulsar la educación stem
es una causa un jefe irrelevante para
toda américa latina pues las
competencias estén sobre el camino para
empoderar a las y los jóvenes
principalmente a las mujeres si queremos
enfrentar como región exitosamente el
siglo 21
necesitamos no solamente decirles a las
niñas sino gritarles que no está de moda
ser tonta que puede reducir como líderes
de innovación y del cambio social que es
necesario no ser perfecta sino valientes
pues está educación en este propone un
aprendizaje basado en la solución de
problemas lo que implica entender
construir probar y mejorar es decir
utilizar el error como base fundamental
del aprendizaje como lo comenté
anteriormente
también esta educación fomenta la
colaboración y una estrategia basada más
bien en roles y no en género por lo que
este es una gran oportunidad no
solamente para el desarrollo sino
también para elegir a integrar a las
mujeres es vital pues además de promover
una sociedad más justo cerrar la brecha
de género en la fuerza laboral puede
aumentar el pib global en 12 trillones
de dólares según datos de mckinsey
se debe hacer hincapié que si no
integramos a la mujer ojalá que por
convicción no hagamos tal vez por bono
demográfico pues esto nos ayudaría a
tener un mejor desarrollo económico y
social en nuestro nuestros países ya que
8 de los 10 empleos mejor pagados son
los basados en estas competencias este
se debe hacer hincapié es muy importante
que no solamente se trata de abrir las
mismas oportunidades para hombres y
mujeres se requiere hacer acciones
tangibles e intencionadas para que se
logren los mismos resultados por ahí
escuché una frase de madeleine albright
que la primera secretaria de estados de
estado de los eeuu que afirma que hay un
lugar en el infierno para las mujeres
que no apoyamos a otras mujeres
y no sé si sea cierto pero ojalá que lo
sea porque es muy importante que
busquemos integrar esta perspectiva de
género las mujeres que estamos en
posiciones de liderazgo para así ayudar
a que otras mujeres desarrollen todo su
potencial y si no lo hacemos pues ya
sabemos en dónde nos vemos los invito a
creer en stem para todas y todas sin
dejar a nadie atrás muchísimas
[Aplausos]